the Church of what's happening now is
brought to you by blue apron blue apron
isn't the number one fresh ingredients
and recipe delivery service in the
country period blue aprons mission is to
make incredible home cook cooking
accessible to everybody do me a favor
check out this week's menu and get your
first three meals for free with free
shipping by going to blue apron comm
slash Joey again that's blue apron comm
slash Joey
you'll love how it feels taste and
you'll be happy to create incredible
home-cooked meals with blue apron so
don't wait that's blue apron calm slash
Joey also brought to you by alikom alpha
brain 24 money minutes not even 24 on
them hundred-percent money-back
guarantee go to Anna's comm slash Church
boom impress Joey and get you a little
out from the rain today on a dog home
slash church.com slash Church let's get
this [ __ ] started
oh [ __ ]
Monday the 28th of August
Labor Day next week [ __ ] here you
go
[Music]
all your dirty briefs out there
[Music]
you
you filthy [ __ ] animals really Sarzo
here lisa a what's up beautiful pass
uncle Joey you know bro putting the
pieces together good day
don't stop laptop every day I gotta
raise a four-year-old at my age jesus
[ __ ] christ how are you I bless a
smurf a go you were just playing
American woman it just came the the
permanent new bass player in the band
The Guess Who so if that's what it is
like for you
yeah I've been touring a lot and just
having a having a blast when you first
went on it was just a temporary basis
you know the what happened was that the
the original bass player they hear on
that song
Jim Cale had not retired fully you know
he had not made the decision yet so he
finally decided to retire at least for a
while you know and then so he passed me
a torch saying okay and how many
weekends are you doing a month with ah
we do about at least three weekends so
much yeah so I'm like you know so it's
just Friday and Saturday no no no not me
we do about 10 shows a month yeah do you
ever get bored playing music or you're
like I wish I'd have to play music this
week oh you must have been told it must
been doing for what 40 years I'm like 50
like it's crazy it's like eating
breathing having sex you know you never
get bored of that you know you know I
always thought I do Comicon 50 and then
you're just too [ __ ] old it's fun old
once listen to some narrow wide air
crack [ __ ] stupid jokes and Here I am
54 and I always said it myself you know
what next year is gonna be the last year
then Ron white comes on he's 60 he goes
on the road every [ __ ] weekend you
know and now you see these music guys
are all coming back then no [ __ ]
spring chickens and they're [ __ ]
banging it out so you like I don't know
what to do I live in hell you know you
decide not to go on the road I couldn't
see my life without going on the road I
think my head would blow up being here
all the time it's been too long I've
been taking these little comedy
vacations that's why it's even hard for
me like I
and I don't want to sound ungrateful
when I have these home weekends they
bother the [ __ ] out because I still have
my life around these comedy shows on the
road it's just about comedy for 24 hours
yeah you know I'm laying in the hotel
room and I'm just worrying about [ __ ]
calm it's like if you got to do the
Pomona grounds and then San Bernadino
your [ __ ] home so you're still gonna
walk your dog you still gotta go to the
supermarket you still gotta [ __ ] take
a [ __ ] there when you're on the road
you're on the [ __ ] road jack you roll
a joint you watch gangland you take a
nap and I get that you got like you do
it for your family but that's why I
don't when you have a weekend like this
weekend when you're in Ontario it's like
I I almost expect you to stay in the air
cuz it's like an hour drive hour and a
half each way no it's a long drive can't
fall asleep knowing that I will not want
a half away I used to do it all the time
try set up the sleep apnea machine lay
down I rather spend the day with my wife
even if we just go to the farmers market
and no hole and get a watermelon juice
I'm one of those Filipino chicken sticks
really somebody's cat is somebody's
pigeon that's missing some magician is
missing a white dove somewhere and these
guys are selling those little [ __ ]
sticks on the corner I'd rather do that
to sit in a hotel room all day when I'm
an hour away from my family that's me
well not when I gotta get on the plane I
go into a different mode and I know you
said something me early on that I did it
cuz of you now I always like saying like
a little prayer to myself as I'm well
God bring me back in the same shape I
walked up this [ __ ] door on Sunday
and that's it yeah I know I know I know
exactly what you're talking about
because to me every time I go out that
door it's about the trip coming back
home yeah that's it you know and make
sure that I come back home you know with
an envelope you did a good show you had
a good time
like everything Oh my whole problem with
the road like let's say this time I
magnet on the 12th of August and I'm not
going out to the 15 to September I'm
gonna work
I still got tons of work but I'd be on
the plane that week before you on the
plane I'm [ __ ] miserable I gotta get
on this [ __ ] plane the whole week
I'm gonna quit doing comedy after this
weekend this sucks ass
as soon as Ober as soon as left picks me
up at my house in the morning that
little lift guy it all goes out the
window I got a little anxiety when you
hit the 405 but after that you're like
I'm gonna work who's better than me I
got a job I'm [ __ ] doing stand-up it
doesn't matter like nothing matters well
what else would I be doing painting a
house I'm gonna [ __ ] perform 20 years
ago this was a dream I would sit in my
room at night cry and writing all the
cities I was gonna play out when I got
good I got me and now I'm [ __ ] doing
it what am I upset about I get into a
great move I eat a couple stars I got on
the plane I start mingling I put my ipod
and I put in [ __ ] diary of a madman
and who I was in a flight you can't wait
til anything gonna do [ __ ] comedy you
know you miss your family you miss your
loved ones but you go what the [ __ ] was
that gonna do at home sit there watch TV
and talk about it's gonna be hot next
week no [ __ ] we gotta do this get the
[ __ ] out here
I admire you rule e he is still out
there
but that's we were talking about earlier
about the doctor we told you about that
he told us that most of the bad people
he had was musicians at that age that's
why you look great I asked you if you
lifted weights you said you don't like
the strain yourself the bass player is
the heaviest thing you want to pick up
you know I do lift some weights but I
you know it's nothing over yeah you
don't go a little beyond your
schwartzman yeah yeah I'm not trying to
Hulk out because what happens is I so
when I travel what I do I do yoga but
extreme yoga in my room just to you know
get my blood you know pumping and you
know getting ready for the show because
you just don't want to go out there and
kind of like be
you know half-asleep you know when you
hit the stage you want to be pumped up
you know so I think I want to read your
guys the best thing for me to do that I
usually hit the [ __ ] gym and do the
elliptical just a little couple weights
and do push-ups and sit-ups just for the
same yes but today I wanted to go to
Jitsu but I knew that I had the long
drive this afternoon so you get all
tight so when you leave the gym then you
sit down I can't recover from that my
knees start to hurt like my fly I gotta
take an aisle seat but on the right side
of the plane so I could stretch out my
left knee if my knee gets [ __ ] stiff
you know like there's all these little
helmets that you have and all these
things that you learn as you go along
and you know wait a second if I don't
work out for two I guessed it I had to
work at night so and I had a long drive
so what I did was I just boxed I hit the
bag a little bit I didn't do nothing
that had my legs involved I did all the
heavy steel bad stuff I did some curls a
lot of push-ups a lot of sit-ups
a lot of crunches all that [ __ ] but no
squats no kettlebells no nothing that
involved bending that much speaking of
fights what do you think about the
upcoming fight what
oh by the time they [ __ ] here is yeah
don't know so I know I know what yeah
what do I think what do I think is gonna
happen this weekend or last weekend I
don't know I really could not put a
pulse on this fight yeah I I can't even
imagine how it actually you know got
sanctioned to happen well got sanctioned
because the state of California gets 8%
of every ticket sold they're making
money even though it's positive that on
it yes okay there's a lot of there's a
lot of people who had problems with this
fight yeah a lot of people the only
reason why this fight is happening is
because of his MMA and whatever you know
they felt Starbound prepared know that
he would be prepared but they're really
scared that Mayweather could hit him
hard
and you know Mayweather's a [ __ ]
assassin with his hands yeah it's it's
an error or game you know I felt that
what's his name McGregor he's been
working on all aspects of his game
pretending 15 years this guy has just
specifically worked on boxing now for
years there's been critics that have
said that boxing and MMA boxing is two
different [ __ ] worlds which it
actually is and but you know listen I'm
not a boxing enthusiast like I was when
I was a young kid yeah I don't know
what's going on but I just didn't like
this fight for personal reasons that was
it
I didn't like this fight because it kind
of halted the UFC for this fight you
know I put a lot of the young fighters
and mm-hmm whatever that's it I just
have my own personal boots I don't care
people watch the fight or not you know I
had taken the week of work before the
fight was announced so it didn't mean a
thing to me it's like I'm gonna cancel a
[ __ ] fight if I can't so Saturday
night is because my friend's dad died
last weekend and they're gonna bury his
dad on something I would take a plane
just to be with him and his sister if I
did anything but it didn't affect me I
don't know why at all I didn't react to
it at all
I have other things on my plate I think
well I mean Rudy you must have as being
on the road as much have you been like
do you even get excited for like events
anymore like you almost can't because
you you have to miss 90% of them like
Super Bowls but ever I don't know what
exactly what you're into but whatever
that you're into you must miss 90% of it
uh events such as the Super Bowl you
know any any organized sports I'm not
really a fan anymore like I used to be
when it was younger because back in the
day when I was a kid it was all about
the sport now he's all about the money
you know free agents and the ages
getting involved and all these
incredible deals that usually what
happens is one when an athlete gets paid
so much money they never come up to
their expectation you know that to me is
the kiss of death you know you hear
about you know this this athletes got
paid you know like the highest ever
interest
bored and Alyssa they start sucking I
don't know if it's a psychological or a
actual economic you know situation that
they get themselves into because now
they have all these different
responsibilities to come up with you
know so I think that that is bad or for
the support for sports for the game
itself you know I this this whole fight
there it doesn't make any sense to me
it's like a sprinter going against a
marathon runner you know if this fight
goes over four rounds which I don't
think is gonna go McGregor is never
gonna over four rounds boxing you know
this is a stamina that you build through
through your life you know when you're a
kid you start training for for you know
for going 10 rounds that's always
three-minute rounds hey yes 1212
three-minute rounds yeah so that's
basically 36 minutes yeah yeah when they
fight in the UFC it's 25 minutes right
which he's never really done only once
really maybe with Diaz
they went to five rounds and people
criticized it about the stamina or
something like that like I said man you
know it's so weird how you grew up like
in sports do you really enjoy sports you
couldn't wait to tour your teams get
together and for me Rudy it was about 26
at 26 life got in the way yeah I've just
gotten away brother and it went from
watching all day Sunday to then whatever
but I'll never forget when I was really
down and out in 84 I was forced to sit
at a bar all day cuz that's where the
action is you know said the bar people
come in they got a hundred quaaludes
they got a pound of pot you gotta be
there and he's always asking myself on
Sunday even at that point in my life how
the [ __ ] do you sit here all day from
10:00 in the morning and watch football
tow and in those days there wasn't no
Duras at Sunday night game yet Sunday
night games were on ESPN very rarely in
those days they were like for Sunday
night game
a season it was all all day and then you
the anticipation was for Monday night
and then how many game wasn't at 14
games - wasn't a shorter season yeah it
was 14 games they didn't really the 17
games is for Vegas to get bigger right
yeah that's what the 17 games was for
you know when I was a kid gambling was
big on Monday Night Football and your
gambling week ended that then you had
Tuesday and Wednesday for basketball and
you paid the bookie on Thursday but your
weekend on Monday but there was really
no action really if you didn't bet
sports if you're a purist and you just
bet football there's really no action
for you until Friday until Saturday
unless you bring high school yeah then
they said [ __ ] that they had khalili
used to have college on Thursdays
then they said [ __ ] that we're putting
pros on for college so they were
alternating like college and pro see you
can actually see the pattern and develop
they did front Thursday they started
with you the bookmaking Saturday you got
all day in college with the last game
being Hawaii at 4:00 in the morning
that's what the cokehead gamblers bet
Hawaii because they'll be up all night
anyway snorting coke watching Hawaii
everybody knows that when you call it
gambling or saddling like that does coke
ask him what he's doing I'm watching a
why they my salvation because everybody
oh there's always this the gambling the
gambling mind believes that people gonna
play football Hawaiian don't go to
Hawaii and play football if they go to
Hawaii they get caught up in the beauty
in Hawaii beats the [ __ ] out him why has
the worst team I know it's gonna say so
you you sit there and you been Hawaii
like you're actually better ye getting
thirty eight points at home and you'll
sit there go and they better not lose by
more than thirty five he's I'm saying
like that was Hawaii and then Sunday you
wake up early and you have football so
what did they do they had it Thursday
and they had
they like the family night the game of
the week that 4 o'clock 7 p.m. game they
have a couple of them too now they'll
have a couple Monday night game
sometimes they have more then I games
they learn how to get the most out of
the system
I just I love [ __ ] everything you
know I like watching football I like
watching baseball you know now it's
change for me now I watch football
December in January I watch baseball in
September there's nothing more beautiful
than baseball in September and October
nothing more beautiful in this country
than baseball
have you watched a documentary about the
Cuban brothers no you know the to that
defected come on which one no Duque oh
yeah you see a document you know I was a
34:30 SPN the brothers in arms they show
the first brother come and then he
[ __ ] played for the Marlins and they
won a World Series and then the other
brother got shunned by the Cuban
government there was glow eggs at his
house they would stop him to shake him
down they took him off the baseball team
he was only allowed to play in San Lots
and then he defected you know the boat
didn't show you gotta watch this dog
they were ready to take him back and
that agent showed up Joe Cuba's and got
him to somewhere where there's no
extradition treaty cuz Jamaica or the
Bahamas has an extradition treaty with
Cuba he got him out of there and then he
brought out Duke gang up to [ __ ] the
Yankees cordon you old violet but the
whole time he leave his daughters in
Cuba so his kids were getting tortured
and [ __ ] so finally he's pitching in the
World Series he's it's games four
against San Diego when they swept him in
1990 something I don't know exactly they
had just won and some lady that they had
kept trying to get his daughters up
they kept trying and trying to trying to
get his daughters out the mother they
had no way that again and they called
this lady in Washington and she goes you
know I'm my mother and my mother
instincts came back to me I felt for
what they were saying
she goes I knew one connection to Castro
there was an arch a bishop she goes I
called him up and I told him you got to
get on the plane that night the cube and
some State Department guy wrote a letter
to fit down explain the situation
that'll do gay they thought he was gonna
say no and the guy was the archbishop
walked into Fidel's headquarters he was
actually watching the [ __ ] World
Series man that's how [ __ ] you know
saying here's a commie watching the
World Series like he was into it like he
was cheering for old Duke a and the
archbishop came in the weather we looked
at it I think you know what the guys are
savage putting his daughters on a
[ __ ] plane and they told no Duke a in
the [ __ ] in the dugout in San Diego
he got in a plane went right to
Teterboro New Jersey and you can stand
there and look at the plane come in oh
my god tremendous dog brothers in exile
that's the name of it oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
and they show the two brothers hugging
and he goes you got any advice for your
brother not easy if you just stay away
from McDonald's
tremendous tremendous Oh a McDonald's
tremendous you know the Castro try it
out for the yen guess you know to be a
pitcher or the Senators Fidel Castro's
how come all these terrible people have
like nice dreams like Hitler wanted to
be a painter for don't wanna hit let's
write out for the Knicks
while the people don't know that yeah
you want to be a Knickerbocker but Reds
red Holzman would take me that's where
you learn to hate the Jews though you're
uh you're an interesting dude Rudy when
I was talking on the phone yet that he
would tell me you had this fantasy can
law confused I thought it was the camp
where you guys get together with kids
and they playing a man but these do you
do yeah yeah we do about eight I have
been doing them for like almost ten
years now this is the deal the the birth
of rock model fantasy camp is from a
former sports agent David fish-off and
he saw the baseball fantasy camp as a
model for the rock n roll fantasy camp
you know having everyday people joining
your you know your sports heroes you
know playing with them right so the
whole thing about rock and roll fantasy
camp is basically the same but except
that which sport you have guys who are
retired you know they're older you know
in the fantasy camp the support you know
baseball fantasy can work with rock and
roll fantasy camp you get people that
are actually active touring musicians
you know for example we have one coming
up in about September 16th and it's
Judas Priest and it's everybody from
Judas Priest Rob Halford you know happy
birthday happy birthday that's right
birthday Rob and you know Scott Travers
and Richie and and the the original bass
player
Ian Hill everybody except Glenn Tipton
they all come Tipton I know he's never
been to the camp you know but there
wasn't a band you know it's fine because
that would show no kaykai's
non-debatable richard for you know
Richie Faulkner is in the band and what
what they do is that we actually we go
to the whiskey down here on the Sunset
Strip and we play and they play with
every single camper on stage of the
whiskey a go go they do one one song
when Judas Priest song with everybody so
they get to perform like you know if
there's like 50
camp camps a camp is actually a band
they'll play 15 you know with 15
different bands you know the band and
and a Judas Priest together and it's an
amazing amazing fun experience
yes [ __ ] crazy
yeah it's not I mean and this you know
Judas Priest is getting ready to to
release a new record so it's not like
they're retired you know how old is he
today
I think it's 66 when I saw that this
gene Simmons - he's I think he's 68 it's
his birthday - yeah yeah listen I can't
believe Ace Frehley 65 and he's put on
in the world yeah he's like on the road
to them yeah well you know the guess who
we have a new record coming out it's
already done finished right now they
were just going through the process of
you know you know putting it out over
you with a with a record company and
doing the doing the the the promo
pictures and everything that we're gonna
do next week and all of that you know
it's it's it's a process did you think
when you know I don't even think about
the last note that I'm gonna play I
don't know I don't think about it I
can't
let's know that I can it's just that I
why why should I think about it's like
what do you think is gonna be the last
joke you ever gonna say I don't think
about yeah exactly you know we're here
to lift not to sit around thinking about
dying I mean I sit here wait before July
like in March I was sitting there one
day one minute before my called Dina
codeine hold on one second before I say
something to you I don't want to be an
[ __ ]
I went I went online and I pressed an
Appetite for Destruction because I
remember the season did that the summer
I got sentenced
I got sentence in 88 and that whole
summer in the afternoons I would get
home at 3:00 and put on MTV and sit
there like a Momo and I would sit that
little sweet child of mine would come
and slash was tremendous on there and
yeah that's right that's eighty-eight
that's next [ __ ] but that album came out
of 87 let me check and see sure enough
yeah [ __ ] thirty years ago July 20th
or whatever was the release of Appetite
for Destruction and here's the crazy
thing
just on the [ __ ] Road oh yeah that
that's the crazy thing when Elvis
released love me whatever in 55 you
didn't see that fat [ __ ] 85 jumping up
and down on stage he was dead Jack these
guys are [ __ ] still alive and that's
great yeah not only that pistol I'm a
foreman three nights a [ __ ] week four
nights a week
did musicians always do that we're like
we did like my mom when she grew up or
her favorite light or from the or not
her maybe her parents from like the 20s
or 30s and the 70s were they playing
however were they not touring yeah I
mean if you look at you know let's say
Miles Davis you know he played until
they he died uh Buddy Rich you know
these are guys that were not retired you
know Sinatra was up there with a wig
with a teleprompter
I saw him forgetting his word singing
the song backwards didn't matter he was
still farm to 184 he was [ __ ] and
brilliant I saw this in effect I went
with Sam Kinison he was performing and
he had it like a night off you know what
Sam we used to play you know you used to
bring musicians and remember he had that
record deal Wow Wow I played oh yeah
and I'm on the video too so you know we
were in Las Vegas I think I think was
Caesars and he says hey let's go and see
Frank so you know this you know his wife
or girlfriend I don't think they were
married yet Milica and Sabrina and my
wife Rebecca me and we just went there
and we sat and and the curtain opens up
and it's Frank and he's just standing
there I felt wow he dad just don't move
and then also him the orchestra goes in
to fly me to the moon you know and he
opens his mouth and it's like magic man
it's just [ __ ] him [ __ ] man yeah I
was 21
I just went I didn't like that music all
in all at that age at 21 yeah you know
it's tough to go from Judas Priest
whatever to that night said let me just
go and it was just [ __ ] marvelous
when he sang my way your [ __ ] gods
come on your guts come on cuz he means
every [ __ ] word of it
like his ego just meant every word of it
like I could just tell that special they
had on them on HBO did you watch that oh
yeah
[ __ ] brilliant just brilliant [ __ ]
and those guys different [ __ ] you
know you know I I grew up playing and
listening to a lot of different styles
you know when I was in top 40 band we
playing anything we had to play whatever
was top 40 it could be my what you know
my way but you're having my baby
Paul Anka or like and then turn around
and play smoke in the water you know you
have to make it work
because that's that's what the the the
club owner wanted you to play you want
to play top 40 whatever is in top 40 you
know so I really learned to really
appreciate what always looked for in
music which we had a lot of that in the
60s and 70s was honesty honesty and the
playing and the singing you know and the
music itself lyrics you know if you
listen to any of the bird Bacharach howl
David songs he's just unbelievable it's
it's a lesson on how to write a song you
know it's incredible listen to Alfie I
know it sounds goofy but if you really
listen to the lyrics it's just amazing
amazing so you know Beals guy oh yeah
changed your world completely from day
one you know and and I was on a plane
you know and you're like going around
trying to find something interesting to
watch and I came upon this was his name
Ron Howard's documentary on the deals
they eight days a week and it you know
in my mind I always go back to that 13
year old kid that saw the Beatles for
the first time when I was it you know
with my with my folks and my I'm a
little
other sitting in the living room with
our TV TV dinner trays you know watching
it Sullivan and the Beatles come on it
and it just changed my life you know
and I thought I thought wow it changed
my life my life because chicks were
screaming at them and I said I want that
really a1 that that you know to be
noticed because I was pretty invisible
when I was a kid I was some fat little
little kid and you know back in the
sixties you know being overweight and
being a kid just was bad it was not a
good thing you know and so I was like
you know girls didn't want to have
anything to do with me and I thought
well becoming a musician that's gonna
give me some sort of significance you
know musician now I am somebody you know
I'm going to be girl screaming at me and
stuff but now you know 40 whatever 40 40
years later or 50 years later I look at
the documentary and I go man what really
got me about the Beatles and I did not
realize it was that they were bad ass
they were so incredible live which I
think they were handcuffed a little bit
when they went in the studio and you
really didn't get that sense maybe on
the first record because from the first
record they had just come off you know
playing in Hamburg doing like you know
10 shows and I whatever you know playing
for hours that would do like playing the
afternoon they would come back and play
at night you know that's all they did
and that's captured its raw you know if
you're listening to money you know that
was like last song that they recorded
for for that session you know money you
know and and there's there's an urgency
and there are badasses just like you
know playing through it like with
everything they got you know and I and I
watch the documentary and this entry has
different angles you can actually see
Ringo Ringo was a badass drummer man he
was just lean in over his snare and just
like bash away and play like then they
have a pH system like we have today you
know they have to be heard over the
screaming girls with no PA system no
monitors nothing the harmonies were
perfect these guys have no any
your monitor nothing you know like all
these people you know complain now this
well my in-ear monitor went out and I
can really sing you know on a Grammys or
something know the people that didn't
matter they just went out there and they
did it and it was just McCartney I'm
looking at I'm looking at the
documentary and I go ok when is it gonna
look at the neck of his bass when he's
singing zero
he's just played away and he was playing
badass stuff I mean to me a Beatle song
is like a bass lesson you know I was
just amazing and it's like perfect and
he's just like orchestrating all these
bass bars it wasn't like you know just
being you know playing [ __ ] up there
yeah the guy was so increased is
incredibly musical but you know but to
have somebody you know to have a band
full of badasses George Harrison he was
like 16 years old it was like kicking
ass you know playing playing lead guitar
it was like holy [ __ ] you know and of
course Lennon you know genius you know
all these guys and you think wow there's
gonna be a whole country full of guys
like this yeah there were but I don't
think anybody compared to the Beatles
The Beatles really we're at the very top
and then everybody will just follow him
you know people's different bands had
their you know strengths like the stones
had there were more arm be more bluesy
than the Beatles were appeals were
Beatles were more pop and then they
became experimental you know with
revolver and Dawn to to Sergeant Pepper
and stuff like that and and you know
here you had the kinks you had who rock
opera who the hell came up with that
that was brilliant
nobody had ever done that have you ever
read the book Pete Townsend book no you
know after and he was having to do with
their managers you know they really
talked them into taking music to the
next level because their managers were
they were cinematographers and they saw
Pete Townsend's contribution to music is
more like a script or film you know and
so they they they talked them into
writing a rock opera which was Tommy you
know and in the book you know Pete talks
about that from that point
every single piece of music he wrote had
a purpose a direction had a a it was not
just a bunch of songs thrown together
he had an arc on a story a statement
everything you know which is totally
different from the average band you know
going out there and making an album you
know we used to make albums based on
snapshots you know it's like it's it's a
snapshot of where you're at today as a
musician your life is this this is why
you sound like this way you look like
which net later on with MTV it was a
company with video you know so those are
slices of our life you know that's why I
always looked at best off records a
little bit more like a collection of
pictures through through a certain
period you know like let's say if you
it's a 10 year collection of your music
it's like pictures you know it's a
little bit disjointed but it's a
representation of what your growth as a
musician that makes a lot of sense even
with comics even when we put tell me
about these yeah yeah I listen to the
Blue Album and I want to jump out of
[ __ ] window but I could tell when I
was listening to the blob I could hear
the cocaine in my soul like it was
[ __ ] crazy live at the Queen o'clock
whatever I can hear the cocaine in my
soul it's you or the priest to me was
the best thing I ever did it was loose
there was no safety net there was
nothing
I was very happy at that time like I was
just having a good time Lee and I would
just start the hangout we're making
videos nobody was there was no real
tickets being sold it was just us having
fun and that you could feel it the eat
[ __ ] with asthma is just god-awful it's
a reflection of what was going on at the
time which was I was overwhelmed
you could hear the overwhelm in your
voice you got too much going on and
there was nothing going on
Tino saying there was too much going on
but there was nothing going on Savage
dad I grew a little bit I could hear the
growth a little bit still not my best
work but I could feel the happiness from
having my daughter around I just heard
on a plane a few weeks ago they told a
few ones besides it's either you and the
priest I can listen to for longer than
four minutes I think you and the priest
is like eight minutes Savage dad is like
six minutes eating [ __ ] with asthma
goes off within eight seconds I mean you
could just hear the confusion in my
voice that early we were working with it
with the record label at the time though
just mainly [ __ ] around
just you guys you know that's that's
really amazing because you know putting
out a quality recording like you were
just talking about with with back in the
day we we had to go through a system the
system vesicle was if you were signed to
a label you were assigned an artist
relations person which meant that the
person picked your material here you
know he came over to your rehearsals
okay let me hear what you guys got for
the new record or your first record so
if you if it's your first record it
means that you've been working on songs
for the last maybe two or three years
you get like maybe 40 or 50 songs to
show you know the the artist relation
guy and then the
you look at it as how many singles can
we get out of these guys because that's
how they make the money money the money
you know longevity and all that because
back in the day record companies did not
have a piece of your merchandise and did
not have a piece of your of your touring
it was all based on how many records
they're gonna sell that was it you know
today's different and then if they
didn't feel like they had about four
possible singles they would say okay I'm
gonna bring in an outside writer so you
know somebody who who has already had
hits with other bands that needed help
in the songwriting and it's your first
record you know or the A&R guy who also
bring a song he said well listen I got
the song either a remake you know for
example like an Quiet Riot was a come on
field the noise was a remake of a slate
song you know and or or something that
he's working with a publisher you know a
publisher is it's an agent
basically for for songwriters
independent writers they go to a
publisher and then the publisher gets
together with record company a on our
guys artist relations and it says if you
can find a band to cover the song you
know we could have a hit so record
company is looking for a hit the
publishers and songwriters are looking
to place that song to be a hit with a
band a band is looking for a hit because
you know there's nothing like getting
your music played on the radio so people
come to your shows and if you got a hit
then you become a headliner which is
ultimately what you want you know you're
an opening band for a certain amount of
period but if you're gonna a few if you
become known as that as a perennial
opening band you're screwed because
you're never gonna get to be the
headliner and that's where the big bucks
are you know and so beyond that you have
promotion people you know radio promo
people going to radio stations and do
and pay all or whatever yeah Paola did
exist then you had the guy that was then
working with a video you know the video
side of your music you know finding the
right director with a storyboard to
complement your music
and having that person bring in stylists
because all my sudden you know you have
to have an image you know like this is
before no image was an image this is you
have to have an image you know and so
not to interrupt me so come on hear the
noise yeah you could tell by the time
you got the white snake all that [ __ ]
was in place already image all that
stuff I mean person right no no the band
that bill Whitesnake was another band
you might quite right yeah yeah I'm
saying well you were there was a huge
change from Quiet Riot to Whitesnake
when it came to metal now they knew what
direction they were going when you guys
did come on hear the noise and the other
one yeah I'm that out yeah
it was those were videos when you guys
when you were in Whitesnake you could
tell that everything was I even think
your outfits we even hand-picked for you
like they were so perfect those videos
in the skin of the night the one with
David katene yeah there was like three
or four videos no white snake head I
think white snake when you were in
Whitesnake 2 albums I played on on slip
of the tongue triplets on you got one
out yeah
was the videos were brilliant yeah two
videos worth it was at the right time
they had just really figured out yeah
how to promote yeah before that look at
breaking the law it's a bunch of idiots
going into a bank and Kate came with a
guitar you know they were like goofy
videos come on hear the noise started
with the guy do you hear me you know all
that guy from Animal House all those
videos were storyboards a tizzy they
knew how to do it something even came
and picked your shoes for you with the
colored socks yeah it's a really good
observation actually it's an oh I can
see it you see what happened yeah I got
a phone call from John Kalodner which
was the artist relation person for
Geffen and and there's a back story to
my to my relationship with Whitesnake
that predates
joining the band because why snake was
the opening band for Quiet Riot in 1984
you know during the condition critical
tour so I got to not only meet I met
everybody and I and I knew John Kalodner
from all the things that I was doing in
in Los Angeles and so I got the phone
call I was playing with Tommy Aldridge
we were trying to do our own project and
they called us up and it says we were
actually invited to play on the record
but that's we declined and that's a
whole different story on the 87 record a
couple of years before he got finished
so going back to 1987 now we're just
like 30 years ago it came out you know
we get the phone call and Kalandar says
listen David wants you to come in and
you know be part of this video that
we're doing for for you know for the new
record and it was still of the night and
they actually they sent over a stylist
this lady came in you know miss fuller
very top-shelf stylist at the time and
she came she went through my closet she
started picking stuff out you know and
it's okay bring this to - to the video
shoot and that's where you see me we're
on that video shoot by the time that
that configuration of Vivian Campbell in
Vandenberg Tommy Aldridge and David
Coverdale myself
we became officially a band then flares
start making outfits for us you know
like now yeah we're not going through
your closet anymore so for here I go
again and it's just love that was shot
back to back like one day we finished
one and then we came back the next day
and we did the other video the those
clothes I you saw they were actually
made for us you know especially made for
us and then we took him on the road with
us
so yeah the record company had not only
that management had a huge part trudi
green our manager you know she will go
to photo sessions with us and she was we
were like you know posing and she would
like move us around and until the
photographer Neal's lows are okay this
is what I'm looking for and when you
would do a photo session the strategy
was to
one that you're gonna have different
looks that will carry you hopefully
through a whole year of touring so you
don't have to break from touring to do a
photo session because that's you know
everything is planned ahead and it's
positive thinking it's not like well
maybe this is gonna happen no no you're
gonna be successful and these people are
gonna make sure that you become a
success you know there's a certain
machine behind all of these superstars
that you see a lot of smart people that
make all the right moves for you
you know that's the way that he used to
be back in the 80s and even 90s until
you know downloading illegal downloading
started happening well even the peak of
it I thought was the marketing they had
done for Guns and Roses
mm-hmm like Volume one and two oh yeah
peak of it Geffen again yeah yeah yeah
biggie smalls 95-96 you know we
advertise with the boats and the [ __ ]
on the boats yeah you know it's a big
difference from the video for ya not NWR
yeah yeah I'm lwase videos there were
nothing they were made for ten dollars
yeah they just told the boy you know a
black pool party but look at the videos
for [ __ ] Tupac and you're mentally
what's his name I shall name Suge Knight
there you know when they did the set
from road warrior Mad Max yeah they were
all yelling by that time those videos
were a million dollars you know all
those [ __ ] guns roses videos for a
million dollars yeah you know expensive
too yeah you're pretty Express I mean
Trudy you know with hhk management
she makes sure that we got the best and
the best was Marty Calder you know
director I mean he's known for all the
things besides music videos like SM fi
he's got his own shows on HBO you know
and he's done like you know live shows
from from my so Square Garden and all
that so he's like you know what it
probably just just about the best live
director that there is so our videos
were phenomenal is I never thought about
it before is that what it isn't that
what music videos are for like a
marketing tool absolutely
yeah Joey and I talk about it a lot we
talk about marketing and all that and
how a lot of people now are very cheap a
lot of people like don't want to spend
on marketing they want to hire someone
for free to that and spending hundreds
of like tens of thousands of dollars on
a video that you're never gonna see like
direct money from like it's it's so it
must be so weird now yes and it's none
recoupable you know the the band
actually pays for it from their
royalties you know like if we make a
badass video this album also whoa all
right let's take Michael Jackson's
Thriller mm-hmm it didn't cost no ten
cents to make those two movies those
yeah those two videos is why that
[ __ ] album sold you know what's three
million when you ever make 35 million
right absolutely because they never look
at nothing it's part of doing business
it was all MTV that's what you saw yeah
all empty empty all I was telling I was
telling was it what you want to call me
or D'Agostino probably understand I
still remember staying home to watch a
[ __ ] guy I just remember going to a
party on New Year's Eve and everybody
stopping at midnight because there was a
premiere a new video oh yeah like that's
how big MTV used to be like you are New
Year's Eve and we're gonna premiere a
video of some [ __ ] guy named how bono
vote I never heard this [ __ ] how
don't know vote before I'll go Nova but
why the [ __ ] would they premiere a video
somebody at midnight on New Year's Eve
he ain't gonna be any good and he shows
up and there's a helicopter
and there's two guys with machine guns
and you hit laser beams and then I don't
know vote jumps off the stage and the
music is men's ammo - you know you're
like wow wow wow wow wow wow wow well so
he just comes running out of a cloud of
smoke and he starts bobbing with the
band and it was okay if you know him
personally now he's like eh he sold two
or three songs like that yeah that's his
claim of fame now yeah but they would
put how many advertisers did they do how
many you have no idea what these do I
still remember [ __ ] and then
postcards and MTV to attend Pat
Benatar's wedding in Hawaii you know why
the [ __ ] yeah that's what they were
doing in the remember one bands would
come to your house and play a show at
your backyard did one of those right
Christmas there you go freakin Christmas
right so it's like wait a minute we just
got off this tour and on that five days
which is during Christmas that I'm gonna
have off I gotta go somewhere in America
to playing somebody's backyard No so
somehow I must be in the best concert
ever like you might you must have been
annoyed you got like ten thousand
dollars quiet right well yeah yeah there
are the people one I got [ __ ]
yeah it was nothing I mean money it was
ocean promotion promo so I'm and and
then the manager calls and said hey
listen yeah the winner is some guy in
Pacoima wherever it was it was you know
driving distance you know they say all
great so I can at least spend Christmas
with my family and then go to this guy's
backyard and and play come on field
because I thought man we're gonna be
stuck somewhere and you know so what can
Fargo Easley you would send the postcard
and MTV of you won you would win $10,000
and a hundred of your friends would be
invited to a pool party with Quiet Riot
personal in your backyard food provided
everything it was like a [ __ ] party
and they came to your house and there
was a couple other bands that did it I
forget a lot we did it so so what came
first empty view of the music video do
you remember aunty
and we'll always the music there were
music videos you know music yeah the
music got a whole channel that just play
music videos I mean that was never done
before alright MTV was created September
of 81
yeah empty became our September 81 you
guys shot videos for blizzard of aahhhs
way before 81
well actually the video that is
available on YouTube from a axis or
cable access station in Rochester New
York that was not done for MTV but was
actually done to promote the show that
we played in Rochester that was the only
real three camera shoot we did with
Randy because there was plans to do a
what what it's known as speak of the
devil from Irvine down you know down the
road with Brad Gillis that was supposed
to be Randy Rhoads playing on that but
of course you know he passed away a few
months before that so the only shoot
that we did with actual three cameras
you know you could edit it that was it
that was it was mr. Crowley yeah mr.
Crowley you know and you know Randy and
I I wrote about it in my book we we walk
in there sits it's a little room it's a
little bit bigger than this you know and
there were maybe like 10 15 people
watching us perform and and it was our
day off and we just took it as a you
know I turned around to Randy and say
well thank God nobody's nobody's ever
gonna see that it became you know it's
the only thing that we have you know
weird with Randy on it you know we we
never knew that was gonna be our only
exposure you know to show how the
brilliance of Randy you know it's crazy
how there were videos but I had never
really seen a music video till MTV
but there used to be a child show up on
USA it also started about 80 to infinity
if anyone was MTV USA had a show called
night flight
oh yeah on Friday night flight yeah yeah
went from 9:00 to 6:00 in the morning we
covered everything
yeah our movie a short film sketches but
they would cover a band like the ten
o'clock segment was a band and they
would play videos that you'd go wait a
second that's 1976 you know what they
just did the 70s on CNN mm-hmm they had
great videos what they're not really
music videos there were scenes from a
concert like heart which crazy on you
won't like that we had midnight special
special we had in concert Don Kirshner
in Congress was rockin those were
brilliant brilliant brilliant another
jeweler would go on there with Ozzie
know by then man I specialist was gone
and in concert too
we did what is the first MTV special
produced for MTV which is speak of the
devil with us performing live at her
vine that that was that was actually
premiere Halloween 1982 what did you
guys do it the Ritz
oh yeah that's a known speak of the
devil that's the real recordings of
Black Sabbath live at the Ritz which
again Brad Gillis tell me Aldrich and
Ozzie and myself that was all so it gets
confusing it gets really two things the
same thing that's what I'm saying the
memory you guys have like I don't know
how you remember shows the name of the
makeup artist or the whatever it was the
the stylist your memory is brilliant I
think the partisan all that [ __ ] because
I really I cherish the blessings of
every single step of my career is that
why
yeah same way I look at times like you
figured you remember those people for
being there absolutely absolutely but I
remember you like Aziz there was two out
let me listen and I'm writing about this
now and I'm thinking of putting this in
to this book like the music like the
chapters name and then the songs of
music I was listening to yeah that that
8081
it was just [ __ ] that Ozzy album and
Pink Floyd the wall before the wall came
on November 79 right something like that
the tour started in February in New York
and those were three months that I want
to shoot myself like I wanted to kill
myself like I was waiting for a train
that hit me but I said I got away from
Pink Floyd I can't kill myself before
Pink Floyd don't make no sense
I paid 1550 I can't die before Pink
Floyd that's a lot of money back then
yeah my mother had died November 8th the
ticket the the the Pink Floyd album came
out like the 23rd or something and that
kept me alive to them worried
and then on February I read an article
that Ozzy was done and of a body was
created in a while and then all sudden I
went I went to Bleecker Bob's in the
city and I saw the four-song EP and that
was more hope for me and you know listen
every time I'm in that car and I hear
nobody ever told you told me I found out
for myself
you gotta believe in foolish miracles
it's not how you play the game it's if
you win or lose you can't choose that's
it that kept me alive with other five
years like that kept me alive that album
kept me alive and then you know the
diary of man man put me over the top to
that time he was biting animals and we
felt it I was telling these guys I went
to a party once and my friends had a
table and a hammer and they were
breaking glass and for you to come into
the party either we eat a piece of glass
like
when Ozzy star leave animals is set my
town on fire one Halloween we went
dressed to the thing as a as garbage and
we all took strings and tied live mice
around their tails we walked into the
party with live mice hanging off the
garbage and then we started pulling up
the mice everybody across the country
was eating [ __ ] animals know
everybody you gotta everybody was eating
the rats head more people after Ozzy bit
that [ __ ] pigeons head off more
people got sick he created a [ __ ] die
it was then a guy went on David let him
listen because Ozzy ate a bicycle come
on I was we were playing in Lubbock
Texas and this is after Ozzy piss on the
Alamo right you know so we were getting
death threats
you know the whatever militia what's in
Texas militia was gonna you know shoot
at Ozzie on stage and we were like
staying away from him or we tell you
come over to us run away from him you
know okay and I'm like doing my you know
my things you know swinging from one
side to the other and I hear this on
stage I feel it we just hit the stage
and I look down and I thought somebody
had thrown a baby on the stage it was
actually a bullfrog
yeah those suckers are huge
down in Texas man they're like baby size
right and people were like bring dead
animals to our show and and security
like stop of them and then they would
take poor Roy's and bring him back safe
and save check out this head of the cow
like somebody just went to
slaughterhouse grab a head of a cow and
brother you know was trying to bring it
on the show so they could throw it on
stage you know so as he could bite it I
was there when Ozzy bit the bat you know
and again I'm doing my thing and I and I
look on the ground and there's this
thing crumpled up thing and I I motioned
to Ozzy hey you know check this out
right so I keep playing and we do her
set so I did not see him doing the whole
thing because I was you know
banging you know and I were getting off
the stage you know we just finished the
show and there's an ambulance ready and
they put him in the ambulance and they
take him to the hospital
and I go what the hell's going on is it
well
Ozzy bit this bad and he thought it was
rubber and he's just been into it then
realized that it was the real thing and
and threw it on into the pit you know
where the audience is they couldn't find
it
you know noted to test for rabies so
they gave Ozzy rabies shots and the the
tour manager comes in the bus because
you know we parked the bus right outside
the hospital waiting for him to get you
know expect out the true magic goes
there Kevin can I borrow your cameras
and yeah boy I take it yeah so it takes
pictures of Ozzie and the nurse you know
hamming it up you know gain the rabies
shot on his leg on his thigh you know
this big nurse you know in Des Moines
Iowa and so you know he comes in with it
with this little box and he puts her in
the fridge and I go what's in the Hat I
go or it's it's it's monkey serum I
gotta I gotta take this every every day
so it started you know getting
injections on the road monkey serum
injections for his rabies yeah what are
the people like was there a bat flying
around and how did a bat end up and
everybody grab a bat and thread onstage
you know listen back in the in the dirt
madman tour we had a little person
Little John George you know little
person and dressed like a monk on stage
that he would be like the guy who brings
Ozzie a towel or or or or you know a
drink or something doing in the middle
of the show and he was actually an actor
this guy had been on Blade Runner and a
bunch of a bunch of movies you know and
and and Ozzie used to like torturing him
and we used to hang him well the crew
did the during our ballad who by to
romance he would be like hanging you
know
my news behind the drums you know so at
the end my monk a monk yeah with a robe
on and stuff you know and he used to
drag a bucket of like body parts you
know like gizzards and intestines or
whatever whatever the runner for the
promoter will go to the grocery store
and buy just desserts and chicken livers
and whatever and throw in the bucket and
and and tripe tripe tripe was always the
best to throw because it was like like
like a lasso you know you could a had
distance if you threw that and a lot of
the times it was not it would not
defrost by the time you know that the
show ended you know so he was throwing
out there like frozen pieces of liver
and and gizzards and whatever you know
one day and what happens is yeah okay he
would start throwing it throwing the
meat out into the audience during
paranoid which was the last song so here
you know we're like rocking out and
there's this dwarf you know marching to
stage slowly someone throwing you know
innards you know animal parts into the
audience that the audience is ducking
you know the first 20 rows everybody
will duck you know but what goes into
the audience comes right back in at
onstage so you spend the second half of
the song ducking body parts again
because that you know liver and shade
that was coming at you as you're playing
you know and one time I got hit I got
hit during a bow because you know you
when you think about with a band you
know you're good you've got your arms
around you know the other guys and
everybody goes down at the same time and
everybody comes up time I see this piece
of liver coming at me as I'm coming up
and go oh [ __ ]
BAM that hit right on the forehead these
are your fans like why honors they're
crazy they just got caught in the moment
did you ever go one of these concepts
with the meat Joey no I live
I would the last IC concert I probably
went to was October of 82 at the
Meadowlands with Brad Gillis whatever
his [ __ ] name was that was it yeah
they had the castle already yeah 82 yeah
was it I had gone to the shows at the
Palladium in 81 with you guys yeah was
with Randy were you there at first a
second show
I think I was down with Friday night I
know me there were two shows one year
earlier yeah yeah but it was just so
weird that was it for me like that was
it no remember any [ __ ] animals or
anything [ __ ] clocking me in the hand
of my daughter people crazy listen man
there's a clip there's a clip from Don
curses mm-hmm
rock concert killing yourself to live
you know and I always look at that clip
and there's three guys in that concert
that that was me and my lunatic buddies
we used to make our own shirts we had a
buddy of mine Mike a Scalise who worked
at Levy's Sporting Goods in West New
York so before every concert he give you
a shirt
I'm of a suicide solution we watch
suicide solution with a joint in between
suicide solution but it was really a
line of coke but people would ask us
what it was and we'd say was a lot of
[ __ ] coke was it's a lady fund yeah I
just I have the guys look at these
[ __ ] lunatics this was this was an
Ozzy concert this was a Black Sabbath
concert which he carried over oh yeah
look at those three morons you see those
three morons that's me and my buddies
with the homemade t-shirts
AHA see Tony Giza Black Sabbath has
returned started right from there white
but push it up a little closer like that
move it up a little earlier Michael more
more more more right there watch him
watch this you wanna look at [ __ ] IL
me Rudy look at him bro he was
for wait till you see these three morons
that was Joey Diaz in his friends but
even look at these three morons but wait
they even go even crazy and watch this
[Music]
watch this watch these three morons
ready his Jodie's look look at the plan
they almost kill themselves
[Applause]
[Music]
look at these three guys they're going
[ __ ] Asian
that's what sadly people just call
[ __ ] nuts man
[Music]
listen I should have all people
[Music]
this is 40 some years ago 40 something
look at them look at them look at them
and one of them is black he can't
[ __ ] believe it
he's like I'm not going back home I'm
done I'm hanging out with white people
watch this one watch this one have a
look we know about it they're losing
their [ __ ] minds
[Music]
[Music]
they still have to have enough putting
these two guys as Joey Diaz they haven't
stopped
[Music]
well are you kidding me are you [ __ ]
kidding me
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
where these three guys ruling Germany
[Music]
none of these three guys gave a [ __ ]
look at them you think they gave a [ __ ]
about Trump or Hillary benefits he don't
give a [ __ ]
Giza Butler you don't give a [ __ ] right
this
[Music]
you think the war gives a [ __ ] what is
Savage
nah
damn then they came back would never say
die and I don't think it was that good
on bankers I think I got it too it's
guys like you were talking about that
makes us musicians you know going
through that it's not it's not about
what we do on stage is all the [ __ ]
that we have to get go through as you
know for you to get on stage all the
[ __ ] you got to go through - for
those one hour hour you know 75 minutes
so you're there it's that audience the
going ape [ __ ] that makes everything
worthwhile oh my god you know my my mom
your you're an entertainer you know what
it's like when the audience is going
batshit
you know you feed write it yeah exactly
exactly that's what they were doing
right there yeah yeah we're gonna take
the [ __ ] to the hilt they got
to leave here going and another thing
that I took from watching that video
again it's being in the tour bus with
Ozzy having a conversation cuz you know
back in the day just know there's no
social social media is nut it's not like
a bunch of guys sitting around with
their iPads or iPhones you're going on
Twitter no it wasn't like you you're
stuck in a tour bus smelling to show
those parts and you got you you know you
have to socialize
you know what are you gonna do there's
nothing you know we had like like in
television video games stick man running
across a TV TV screen you know it was we
had VHS cassettes we had nothing so you
do is you sit around you talk and drink
you know if you're into drinking
whatever so you know without seeing we
go hey I see you have a Beatles fan and
it goes human Beatles to change my life
you know the Beatles of my favorite did
and then he goes yes and it's just son
is so evil the way that he's saying you
could sing happy birthday you were like
joining in
happy birthday to you
and he's like holy [ __ ] you know that
the Klaus are come rolling in it gets
dark
could be the happiest song but he puts a
hand to do my [ __ ] yeah he could [ __ ] up
that Jewish song whatever they won't
even want to jump up and down the Jews
they're like what the [ __ ] happened
yeah take the envelope a kind of no mood
for this aggravation
Carlton Shackleford you bad [ __ ]
Ryan Donnelly latisha Caton Nick Bonanno
Derek Winslow Jordan Cato Oh bar muscle
you're a good man Sabbath Wilkinson and
my man pretzel worst you know I love all
you [ __ ] guess what I got no
dates so I'm off for a couple weeks
September 16th I'm in Oklahoma at the
casino and then the end of the month I'm
the charity because you know I think
write thinks it's called me at the end
of the month I'm at the Pittsburgh
improv and I'm right I'm taking care of
[ __ ] Rudy what do you got going
you're a shout-out to my godson he's one
of your yes fans yes
Vinny Vinny Pio vide Fiat oh I love you
papa
why are you in Miami and Miami being
Doral down there
Doral yeah next year boy that's that's
close yeah yeah I'll be down there next
year yeah there was when when were you
gonna be there they're gonna open up a
club and they just called you then they
say you interested in there and opening
it I'm trying to find the 600 seat seat
theater in Miami that's what I'm trying
to find hey your seat theater I could go
down there and do two shows on a Friday
and get it over with it's not building
this [ __ ] Cuban thing I want to start
building it down there yeah I want to
start going down
working like there's a place called
Magic City casino I know and I may like
fireballs they keep breaking my balls
about that casino so let's see what the
hell happens they found one in for a
while but I don't want to play that's
too far that's too far too far yeah what
I want to do so it's just been a
nightmare lately but there was something
I really want downtown Miami that would
be a good I would be even like the
Jackie Gleason theater oh yeah you know
what it seats well it's big it's big
yeah for the last two years we've been
losing a lot of music just a handful
from Greg warm and [ __ ] Prince but
this year we lost two of them to the
same [ __ ] thing you know and I mean
when you and I first met we were here
and this one I think we're in the other
office and we were talking about how
with musicians comedians there's a thin
line with mental illness you know you
know we and I had a we had doubled a
podcast in here about depression you
know he was feeling a little down did
you go talk to you people today I'm not
today I'm going next week next week she
didn't go this week not to speak you
[ __ ] up already so you know we're just
talking about things you know I feel
[ __ ] different times in my world you
know I get feelings in my head that are
not evil nothing but I'm just not
feeling what I should be feeling even
family maybe you'll find yourself and
you're like why am I feeling like this I
have no reason in the world I feel like
this why do I feel this way this year
we've had two musicians you know Chris
Cornell's we're here every [ __ ] day
on the radio to rub salt in your wounds
you know I feel like writing a letter
for the radio stations and gonna stop
playing Freedia please a year because I
can't even get over it you know I like
the other band you know but it's not
about whether you like abandoned that
the kids still took his life or the
[ __ ] shame from Lincoln Park
and what the [ __ ] what you know now
you're hearing all these stories they
were part of a child pornography ring
and they went in and hung both of them
you know these [ __ ] people don't stop
with the conspiracy theories you know
they found no obvious heroine and Chris
you know they found whatever it was he
had in the system you know do you have a
take on this the theory behind the child
pornography ring was that they were
about to uncover they were about to say
who was involved they were not involved
in it no they were completely against
against then you know to some lucky guy
knocked over some letter which is like I
got to go to church and killing chickens
kill the chicken so yeah it's it's you
know I've I worked with people that I'm
not gonna name of course it's you know
who had some mental issues you know it's
it's unfortunately and I think it's not
just music it's entertainment industry
or even even sports you know if you are
a big money maker if you if you as an
artist or an athlete generate a bunch of
cash for a bunch of people they're gonna
keep feeding you and keep you out there
for as long as possible you know and you
basically become disposable to them you
know because you're gone sometimes you
even generate more more money for them
after you're gone look at all this look
at Michael Jackson you know all of these
you know it is very unfortunate because
it's you know III can't judge anybody
because it's their journey we each have
our own journey and I'm not here on this
earth to judge people you know it's very
sad that it happens and I just hope that
it stops very soon if people are able to
to offer help but you know sometimes
when you're so if you're on the road
man that could be the loneliest place
ever you're in your room all by yourself
sheds are coming through your head it
can be very dark very very dark even in
the bunk of a tour bus man you know
you're going to traveling and [ __ ] going
on through through your head you know
especially if you happen to have mental
illness you know it wasn't about the
comedy was about seeing friends it
wasn't about the food in Houston it
wasn't about the Chinese food in Florida
it was all about the drugs there for two
weeks I'm gonna make 1,300 bucks I'm
gonna come home with 200 I'm gonna drop
everything else I'm blow and have a good
time and it's it's not lonely it's
lonely that morning you're sitting on my
[ __ ] doing you know there's just so
many ups and downs to this business that
people don't really know about they they
see you one and you're Netflix special
you know cracking jokes walking around
they think you lived there you're the
life of the party I love when women
start dating for medians I love when
when we start dating comedians and after
90 days they tell their friends at work
this new guy I'm dating oh my god then
they all get together and come and see
him and they tell her it must be a
barrel of laughs living in the house
with this [ __ ] joking and within
three years you see what [ __ ] barrel
after this to live with a [ __ ] comic
and just as a flip side to that laughter
there's a flip side to that happiness
there's a yin and a yang
Sam and you pay for all of it and it's
the same thing with music only a
different energy you're putting out
music you're not exposing yourself which
in the way you really are you know
people are seeing you tonight under my
deal and at the end of it all everybody
goes back to their room and here you are
in your room by yourself
and the party's over and yeah but I have
so much respect for guys like you
Sam Kinison you know all my buddies jim
Florentine you know Greg gasps you know
guys who get up on that stage with
basically your dick in your hand all you
got you know we got amplifiers we can be
louder than anybody you know we got
lights
we got fireworks we got big screens it's
just you and a microphone out there and
I couldn't do that you know you're
baring your soul to the audience how do
you do that I don't know I don't know I
said here I figured gave me permission
gave me permission to think that I was
gonna be like I didn't get the memo that
I was gonna be in Ozzy Osbourne's band
after he broke up a Black Sabbath I
didn't I didn't get that memo you get it
really I didn't get this memo about
comedy I never got this thing that this
is what he was gonna end up like at all
booty when I got into it was just to do
some of my life I didn't get I didn't
know anything I love Richard Pryor and
I'm loved we stood for and when he lit
himself on fire with the coke I loved
them even more the other one that I read
the Lenny Bruce book and I even became
more fashionable becoming a commoner but
I didn't have the
to get on stage come on this is a great
idea but then I got locked up and I
would go up and [ __ ] with the [ __ ]
Invictus during the week and then I
realized this is nothing this is what
I've been doing all my life there's a
part now what's that we were Pacino we
plays the football coach Jamie Foxx with
them who come here yeah it's a quarter
to five your mother's gonna call your
mother just called Jenna for dinner you
got one play left remember you made the
guy run to the Cadillac and hook a
[ __ ] right same thing it's the same
thing I was doing I'm 54 you know it was
the same thing I was doing maybe I don't
know when I was 15 in front of a deli in
front of 12 people I'm doing the same
thing I was doing in the deli talking
about we went to a party a day let me
they were [ __ ] rude this [ __ ] no
I didn't I didn't make up with the chick
you know he took down a tree in a zip
line no I didn't take anything down Lee
what I've got a Groupon and that's what
I'm saying
we didn't take the zipline down but
that's what I would tell my friends and
they would start from there yes you dig
[ __ ] and you use the Groupon and
then from the everybody would chip in
that stand-up comedy you're just doing
it in front of your [ __ ] friends
yeah and then the closer would be a
chick would walk by and I think Mike
Ditka and ask her a question like some
woman I was like nine and I would think
my dick I that's good question then we
ran away
that was the closer the same thing was a
performance I've been doing this all my
[ __ ] life well not even knowing you
didn't even know it you know on Fridays
in the sixth grade I used to have to go
to the front of class and sing my eyes
adored you
bye Frankie yeah yeah every [ __ ]
Friday yeah and I actually thought I was
Frankie Valli I in power it's the things
that are right in front of your face
that you end up I just do it the higher
man
now I do it in front of 300 people a
night that's the 12 people in a [ __ ]
delicatessen you know I'll never forget
first day I ever stood on stage as a
musician you know the first gig you know
it was in Miami we you should have this
thing called open houses which was not
an open it was nothing to do with real
estate was actually it's some sorority
group or some little gang were financed
this this dance you know and the so
there were higher bands and that's what
the chicks were you know it's kinda like
a social thing you know and we had a
band and I stood in the on a stage and
it was a proscenium stage so there was
like an enclosure and I I'd never seen
this before but I actually saw like an
energy like a shield protecting me from
the audience protecting me because there
was some pretty rough kids out there you
know and once in a while they'll have
like an inner inner fraternity fights
you know you know between different
fraternities you know coming you know
somebody will get stabbed or shot at
it's Miami you know with bunch of Cubans
you know back in the 60s and man I stood
up there and I felt safe for the first
time in my life safe in a sense I was
not gonna get emotionally hurt because I
used to get emotionally hurt a lot you
know first of all you know coming from
Cuba to the United States
you know weekly when we arrived from
Miami in 61 they were trying to avoid
what eventually did happen which is the
Cubans taking over you know Miami was a
sleepy little town you know tourism in
Miami Beach and that's about it you know
no real industry except for building
yachts you know that's about it and so
here comes these Cubans all of a sudden
is like oh [ __ ] are we gonna you know
hired these people there's no jobs you
know that's how we got relocated to to
West New York you know and we became
basically undesirables you know so I was
in the undesirably I tell you the
original Syrians we were undesirable
because we were Cuban refugees and then
I was undesirable because I was a fat
little kid in the 60s and just all along
I was undesirable so I was emotionally
really beat up you know until I started
playing music and you know coming from
Cuba you know people ask me about
politics and then go you don't want
politics when I was a kid completely let
me down first of all you had you know we
were you know this I was about 11 years
old by the time we left Cuba and so you
know at 11 you know what's going on you
know you see this this revolution that
just happened and this guy comes on TV
and starts making all these promises and
before you know it things get really
[ __ ] up and my family has to leave the
country and take us so that was my first
real and you know downer or you know
about politics you know so we get to the
United States and things are really cool
politics once we got kennedy and he's
really a good you know good president
and the country loved him and he gets
shot
well that's second you know there's no
stability
nothing not there's nothing here to
protect you
you know politicians are not gonna
protect your government's not gonna
protection my mom and dad they're doing
their best to take care of me but this
is on stable because even somebody that
you're rooting for somebody you really
appreciate that's what you know that
doing something for the country they
could be snuffed any moment now you know
it just happened you know or this guy
can come in and make a bunch of promises
and turn out to be a liar you know and
you got to leave the country it wasn't
until the Beatles came in that was my
salvation it gave me hope life all the
sudden we got music music you know music
has never let me down I I might have let
music down I could have maybe a certain
part of my life I didn't devote myself
enough to the craft of music but it's
always been there I don't know be for
music music let me
down one time when I went to see black
Simon would do Sammy Hagar I was opening
up for shakin Street I was never so let
down in my life in the same way I was
one of the worst shows of my life but I
love the oh yeah yeah yeah but you know
it's just once I devoted my money and
say okay this is what I wanted to you
know I came to LA and I burned my ship
it was I I didn't have any plan B I was
gonna do what I am doing
it wasn't like well you know if it
doesn't happen I'm gonna be a shoe
salesman or whatever no no I mean it and
it was a religious experience for me to
actually get that call from Ozzie you
know that changed my life you know to do
what I'm doing today because III bring
everything else that that a bit that
I've done for the last since 1981 to
that moment that's the moment that it
happened changed my life you know and
even though I have made peace with God
and everything there was no plan B you
know that was it I was sleeping on the
floor and I got that phone call it
wasn't like well you know meanwhile I'm
selling shoes that pelas or whatever no
I was I was gonna be a musician and
that's it I was a starving musician you
would stop in the street and say hey
dude what are you what are you what do
you do I am a musician you know to me it
just starts with that pre-visualization
I am I am this you know without that you
just don't have any any platform to
really stand on for what you believe or
you believe that you can be someday I
listen truly I told you I had the same
problem when I came here this was it
this was it this was it if something
good didn't happen
I wasn't that my uncle and go the plane
and go to New York and try to sell drugs
that's it that was it there was no plan
B I was out of Plan B's I was out of
Plan B's Jack you know I was 28 maybe I
wasn't him to call me 91 so I was 28
years old
I already been to prison I already
spelled drugs that worked for a printer
I did everything this was the last ray
of hope in two years just to get to
understand the magnitude of what I was
getting myself into
you know I'm saying like I thought you
went up on stage somebody walked in and
saw you that makes Bo special and you
were a comedian that's it I didn't know
that you had a right jokes and stuff I
totally know all those specials you see
I took somebody would just call you that
morning what he's known for that come on
down we'll run a camera coming do 40
minutes
that's what I thought it really was and
then I realized what the parameters were
how hard you had to work and again you
have another decision to make correct
when you realize when you joined Ozzie
when you join Quiet Riot this should
start a rock and roll it this was a long
step from you guys in the garage [ __ ]
around smoking three joints playing come
together or run or help the scalp there
even saying yeah this ain't helpful
scalp to the floor that guy in the
corner that's a Jew and he answers to
another string of [ __ ] Jews and then
here watching you so you make songs that
sell money because that's how you
coexist that's how you know it's a
different game yeah you've come a long
way since that garage yeah for me it was
the same thing I was doing I was
following line dance classes on a Sunday
night in the country-western bar bombing
on th know and then Boulder and in
Denver I was doing common that's why I
started and next thing you know I'm in
the 2000 seat theater opening up for Joe
Rogan you know opening up for Paul
Mooney open
Freddy Griffin you know opening up for
dice in Vegas you know I went from the
one extreme to the next and now you're
like wait a second but there's a big
moment where you have that doubt did you
ever have that doubt at all were you
like this is what its gonna take
because when you join them when you were
already an Ozzy you had already a little
bit of taste of fame from quiet right no
not really no no no luckily only lowly
and though you know this it's not gonna
get you anywhere you know you're just
local big fish in a small pond you know
and it's but and the pond was getting
bigger and drying up because at that
time that I got a call from Ozzy it was
all about new way from Punk here in Los
Angeles
it wasn't about rock and roll you know
rock and roll as we know it or became an
in the 80s you know you have bands like
Motley Crue and rad and and and and
Dokken just playing locally or you know
trying to get that break you know you
know it was it was it was a whole
different different LA but it's really
interesting that you said you said the
same the same premise when I came here
and I think that's what la is la is the
place where if you got a dream this is
what you've come to you know you don't
go to Fargo to fulfill your dream unless
you're a farmer you know you come here
so this is what really separates LA from
makes it different from the rest of the
country you know this is a place where
and where winners and losers all come
here for that shot that one shot man
this is it this is like this is a bigger
gambling city than Las Vegas because
you're gambling with your life your
future here you know you could lose your
money at a table and still make the
money again but to lose your life to
lose your future who you are not to
really accomplish your dreams that's the
biggest loss you could ever have ever
not to always what was the word in
accomplished dreams laughter even
accomplish your dreams but not even to
go for them that was my biggest [ __ ] my
biggest fear was going [ __ ] I had but
least you had a dream you know how many
people I know that don't have a dream
don't have a dream they're just happy
with you know god bless him because we
need everything of you know we need
everybody to be different things but
that wasn't us that wasn't you that
wasn't me that wasn't the people that
that have come to LA to make it you know
and I know people in LA that came here
to be musicians they you know they
happen to arrive at the time where the
music industry was shutting down but
they have no choice they came here and
they actually became bigger successes
and field outside of being a musician I
got personal friends of mine
we're like huge industry people that you
talk to them say well yeah I came here
to LA trying to you know getting the
band and and do this and they fail at
that but boy they're like the biggest in
their field that is that was always a
blessing luckily I came here to be an
editor the day he called me he was gonna
apply the pizza place and he didn't show
up and a fundraising thing for like a
democratic or like just a political
phone raise a fundraiser on the phone I
was up I was applying the second jobs
cuz I guy I was I wasn't making enough
to survive we started making videos for
a hundred a week shoot a video we would
talk about different things but if he
never would have contacted me he would
have been back in Boston today
just making the effort sometime yeah
absolutely
what have happened if he would have gone
back to Boston I started a podcast and
you would have been listening to an
outgoing I wish I would have [ __ ]
contact with him yeah I mean that's you
know that's that that was always my
biggest fear buddy
how much how much thought did you guys
put into coming here cuz everything I
think one of my biggest issues in life
is always overthinking things
and I notice when I want to just do
things off of a random whim they you I
mean not always but they tend to go okay
it tends to go better than I thought it
would so like I I was just in an office
like they kept me working for the summer
because they were very nice they loved
me so they were just that will keep you
here there's nothing for really you for
to do so I was just hanging out on
Facebook trying to be like look like I
was busy so I would do some things and
then I I just wrote you a message
randomly everybody growing up wants to
do the right thing you know we all want
to do the right thing I think the day I
made the decision to become a comedian I
let everything go that was the day I
stopped thinking about things that
wasn't there stop worrying about bills
that was there stop worrying about what
day it was it doesn't really matter you
have a mission to do shut the [ __ ] up
get up go do it and that's it that was
the day you it's it's it's it's a
horrible [ __ ] thing because you have
to suck 20,000 dicks a woman has to suck
20,000 dicks before she finds a prince
what do you think we do as men we gotta
suck 2,000 dicks we gotta work
construction work this work that until
we figure out what we want to [ __ ] do
but once you do it and you think about
it for maybe a day and you decide to
give it a try and you stop thinking and
you just do
thinking is the enemy of man it's the
destructor of man once you get thought
and once you start giving yourself
obstacles what if I do lose you just
lost yeah you just lost yeah what if I
did
well if I try it I don't like it okay
you know what yeah you just said the
word if I try it I don't like it yeah
you already committed out of it
you're out of there in three weeks just
because you said that just because you
relied your mind to go there you just
quit already through some nights in the
last three weeks seven last three weeks
I think it up when I came to Iowa I had
nothing to lose
I had no what a [ __ ] go I was just a
comment I ended up to Seattle with a
stripper and I thought the goal of
coming I thought coming to LA meant you
had to be the best of the best of the
best in your field and it didn't mean
that just coming here makes you a better
person in a way absolutely it lifts your
level and then once you get here it's
like anything else
you would that and I just is that the
word and you [ __ ] run with the ball
like you know what you're doing even
though you don't yeah that was what it
was for me I ran with the ball even
though I did not know what was going on
you know I'm how much I used to torture
Richie super in 1998 that's another
success story you know he used to find
him hate me because I'd knock on his
door with that office and go yeah what
are you gonna put me on the road dog you
missed it last night I killed just cuz
you killed don't mean you [ __ ] gonna
be a success now get the [ __ ] outta here
kid that would leave them alone you know
yeah you're right now he's got to be a
company now he's got to [ __ ] be a
company you know you never know till you
wake the [ __ ] up out of bed and do
something with your life that's it
that's what I say every morning just get
up just get up bro get up and get out it
might be walking and bump into a [ __ ]
CD a CB radio salesman and he talks you
into becoming a CB radio salesman
where's the CB do you don't use the CB
no more but there's gotta be 3,000
people are still stuck in the CB and you
find all of them and sell them new CDs
every you know every [ __ ] seat has an
when isocell cars like to look at that
[ __ ] green car was gonna buy that and
had an old car manager live in Oakland
every seats got a basket somebody'll
come in here and buy no we play this I'm
here but that would be one man's chicken
is another man's gumbo dog it might be
an ugly car to you but the Sun guy Wow a
green car I want that [ __ ] day yeah
you know I just want to go back to one
thing you mentioned before which it was
the letting go factor to me doubt that
was the key to me as soon as I let her
go
it's just he's just poured just let it
go let it let it happen you know what I
mean it's like doing like you said don't
don't don't defeat yourself by having
the negative thought that it's not gonna
happen
don't worry won't worry about it it's
gonna happen you know if you look at if
you go back a hundred years Los Angeles
Los Angeles it's a place that has been
built upon people that came here with a
dream you know back going back to the
silent era you know like all these men
and women that want to be part of these
silent movies and and then you know you
got radio television and then finally
you know eventually music became a part
of it you know so this is generations of
dreamers dreamers even if you were like
you know my wife she is not in the
entertainment industry but her word her
dad came to LA to LA you know from the
Midwest because he wanted to be a guitar
player he wanted to be a musician you
know so it's it's generations of
dreamers that make up this whole this
whole area this whole place this is one
of the most unique unique environments
in the whole world
I never thought about that way I think
of my parents leaving Cuba yeah
before the Revolution you know like they
knew something that maybe yeah
they laughing like my dad left him like
52 or something he was a young kid he
goes [ __ ] this [ __ ] you know he did what
most people do they just left after high
school yeah they just got up and they
said [ __ ] this I've had enough of this
Island living
gilligan still hasn't showed yeah yeah
so what do you got coming up more shows
with uh with the guests who we have an
album coming out that's the rock and
roll fantasy camp September would you
just priest a whole bunch of stuff you
know man like this is a Monday morning
podcast and I think just the last 15
minutes of this podcast was so strong
for Monday morning about like where it
all starts with your mind people don't
really believe that [ __ ] but it's true
Rudy for me it started when I said I'm
getting at the Carly I don't give a [ __ ]
I'm on my credit bureau I don't give a
[ __ ] about the credit card people I
don't give a [ __ ] about the banks you
were [ __ ] about what I Drive I give a
[ __ ] about what my clothes on because at
the end it doesn't really matter unless
you're happy for years I worried about
my channel Robin
I gotta have white sneakers or nothing I
have a black shirt on it who gives a
[ __ ] at the end of the day I wasn't
happy I wasn't happy I didn't get happy
till I started driving cross-country
with a pair of shorts on and stinky
sneakers and the t-shirt and you got
three pair of jeans and three shirts and
they're lasting you all week dog you got
like four pair of socks and you get on a
stage that's what I really started
getting happy when I started waking up
in the morning and knew I had to drive
200 miles and I had thirty to fifty in
quarters and I had to get lunch with
that reefer and gas to get me that next
location for some reason I'd be [ __ ]
happy a lot happier than making [ __ ]
1,200 a week and paying my bills I was
like this is what I like I like this
it's food for thought sometimes it's not
about the money or the dollars it's
about what brings a [ __ ] smile to
your face you know finding the joy and
whatever you do in life you know
whatever you choose whatever your dream
is you know it's gotta be joyful and
once you find that let yourself go think
about it don't look back yeah
don't compare prices yeah don't listen
to your uncle about taking the roofing
job for 1254 stability yeah you know
what stability is overrated don't
stability is overrated absolutely I
think happiness is [ __ ] doing what you
want to the [ __ ] health and even in
there bro right I was in County for I
was in County for 12 years before I saw
a dime yeah we were getting paid but
nothing to write home about I could have
quit at any time in those 12 years and
found the job I would had tricked
somebody into being an indoor salesman I
didn't want to do that I would have
rather live on eight thousand a year and
do my own thing and [ __ ] around it made
a smoked pot with your stupid buddies
and get on stage then going to an office
insurance who gives a [ __ ] when you
think about insurance that's when you
need insurance for 30 years I ran around
with no insurance nothin ever happened
to me once I gotta share this one I
started getting cut in two it takes and
[ __ ] hemorrhoids and you [ __ ]
hurts this [ __ ] when you have no
insurance in you're not worried about it
you're fine nothing happens to even
others that [ __ ] yeah I mean I just like
you went through your own journey you
know mine was after Randy died I just
lost all the joy of playing you know
because every now we have to go onstage
and it was a reminder of the tragedy you
know and I actually left Ozzy to join
Quiet Riot which was the biggest unknown
you know like nobody in LA believes in
the band we had like you know a really
bad record deal but ELISA was a record
deal and but we couldn't even get
management we had to beg people to
managers and you know I was like these
guys are you know but as soon as I got
my butt on
the first few shows that we did we
rented a station wagon and we drove up
to San Francisco to play at the
Keystone's up there and and the joy of
music came back I had just left one of
the biggest bands in the world and Here
I am playing with the you know with with
my buddies basically a girl you know a
GarageBand level you know driving around
in a station wagon and but it was happy
again now wasn't it come on hear the
noise and all that come on well I mean
it came out on the radio but you know
what year
boy it's 83 so okay so you had that
success with them no wait without Z
first right with Ozzy first not quiet
right then quiet right now what's the
record that you guys have you guys have
it's the number-one heavy metal album
yeah well you know is actually the first
debut metal album to reach number one
okay there's no go away because I saw
yeah and this is doing the the time were
to go to number one you had to sell
about a million copies a week you know
it's a lot of Records I mean you know
like today you know like all these
people who were great getting Grammy
Awards or whatever they don't even you
know get sell a million in a year you
know it was just because you know
downloading and you know illegal
downloading and everything that goes on
you know I mean basically nowadays you
make a record so you can go to a
promoter and say hey you know got a
brand new record you know give me some
shows back in the day was you you you
did the shows to promote the record now
you do a record to promote the shows you
don't make any money on records nobody
does and we're trying to find like
that's what we do meet and greets you
know VIP meet and greets you know
because it kind of like covers because
of whatever touring costs we get you
know the compensator and so merchandise
and stuff like that I can catch the
evens 300 hours at the Beacon Theater in
New York City the prices for the tickets
are ageist but people have to know
there's no more record sales yeah
there's only one band that's someone
make money this year that's kind of
roses yes they will release a lot our
studio record that was Rober early on
yeah release one this year I don't know
anybody who let who's bought the record
it's a Stones record come on it was like
you know it's this for you back in the
day you and I you know yeah just get it
you know it was automatic it's a
different [ __ ] game yeah there
brother sure is always a pleasure you
know I love me the dense like I said I
got no [ __ ] dates to promote it's
Labor Day this podcast is for you and I
just gotta tell you two or three things
and I'll be out of your hair number one
as usual blue apron [ __ ] it's number
one fresh ingredient and recipe delivery
service in the country their mission is
to make incredible home cooking
accessible to everybody all right well
that's a beautiful thing at each other
cook as a family because let me tell you
something families who cook together
stay together I don't care what you say
or what they tell you you know my
experience with blue apron has been
tremendous please had a bla great
experience with them they come the
products are measured there's no waste
everything goes in and what you getting
yourself as a delicious delicious
home-cooked meal and you know what 45
minutes or less then you know they're
affordable for $10 per person per meal
boy better deliver the seasonal recipes
along with proportion ingredients to
make tremendous home-cooked meals you
get a variety you choose get a variety
into recipes each week well let Bruins
killing every team surprise you recipes
are never repeated within one year so
you'll never be bored you're customizing
your recipes each week based on your
preferences and there's no weekly
commitment so you only get the
deliveries when you want each meal comes
with a step-by-step listen to me
step-by-step easy to follow a recipe
card and proportionate ingredients can
be prepared in 40 minutes or less if I
could do it
you
do it boy opens freshness guarantee
promises that every ingredient your
delivery arrives ready to cook or
they'll make it right let me tear this
week's menu summer vegetable with egg
paninis with Calabrian chili mayonnaise
and a caprese salad
you never dreamed of making a compress
salad soy glazed pork and rice cakes
with bok choy and marinated green beans
I don't even know what bok choy is
skillet vegetable chili with cornmeal
and cheddar drop biscuits are you
kidding me
garlic butter shrimp and corn with green
bean salad and roasted purple tomatoes I
thought dr. Zeus had purple tomatoes but
that's not how it works out
listen is what we're gonna do check out
the menus just some you want I'm gonna
tell you what I'm gonna do I'm gonna
give you three free meals with Free
Shipping by going to blue apron coms
last Joey you know love how it tastes
you know love how it feels and gonna be
happy you have to create incredible
home-cooked meals right in your house
with blue apron so don't wait right now
give it a shot bro give it a shot
you want to lose weight the whole thing
this is how to do it this is the start
right here blue apron dot-com slash Joey
blue apron a better way to cook all
right number two on it best supplements
out there alpha brain it don't work for
you you don't like it whatever yeah I
don't know I started thinking about
Martians you don't like it
you said you don't even have to send it
back and they'll give you a money-back
guarantee 100% they also have to have
forced protein you got the shrimp export
shrimp check immune if you fly all the
time you keep your immune system up and
that's it and that's that I love your
[ __ ]
see you Wednesday stay black stay
healthy and have a good [ __ ] day all
right
and don't let nobody [ __ ] tell you
more me and Rudy told you it all starts
with your [ __ ] dream have a great day
love you